I have a topic I wanted to bring up with
you which is near and dear to my heart
because it's been the root of this
podcast I've been doing for about five
years I get to talk to a lot of quote
important people people that have
achieved amazing things and what I try
to get them to talk about the things
that uh that they they thought of as
maybe a disability or a problem when
they were younger that helped fuel them
that when they were younger they
desperately wished it would go away they
thought of it as a weakness but when
they look at the span of their life now
they see that that actually uh helped
Forge them and I know you've talked
about this but you when you were growing
up and stuttered and it must have been
the fuel in some ways to have pushed you
forward well when I was
a
kid you've got this problem licked by
the way for me it was uh I was really
lucky I had a mother and a father that
uh my mother would say don't let this
Define you look at me Joey you're
handsome you're smart you're a decent
young man don't let this Define you
taught me how to fight there used to be
a a joke in when I was growing up in
grade school and high school that uh you
know you could beat up Biden but he'd
hurt you going down right the point was
that it made me realize in our family
this is God's truth conent four of us we
were never allowed to make fun of anyone
no matter how mean they were to us if
they had something they couldn't
overcome right swear to God if you did
you get your rear end kick when you went
home not a joke and so it taught me that
there's a lot of people dealing with
dilemmas that take away their pride
their dignity I I don't know whether
it's a thing that pushed me about one
like for example even though I was a
stutter I ended up being elected to
class president kind of thing I mean but
it wasn't I didn't run for that reason
it was something about your dignity and
your pride yeah it it doesn't just
manifest itself in terms of an
impediment you can for example when we
were kids there were a couple Hard Times
financially for my dad and I remember
being invited to was talking to this
about my sister last night my best
friend and we were going to the a catian
at Mount Pleasant High School which was
R the best high school in Delaware and
an that was not overwhelming but a
fluent area MH and we lived in not bad
area but a less a fluent area and I was
invited to the catian and I went to the
Catholic School uh St Lenas in that
district and it was you know it was just
a little different I remember being
invited and I I was anxious to go and my
mom my I had a uncle who lived with us
at the time he was 5'7 and uh my mom
couldn't find a white shirt for for me
and so we got one of his shirts and with
French cuffs on it and my mother and and
it fit Loosely but fit my dad had always
wore cuff links to work and my dad had
the cuff links we couldn't find it I
didn't know what to do so my mom goes
downstairs over the washing machine in
the basement in the garage level and
gets two nuts and bolts and brings them
up and puts some on me and I said no
swear to God my word today that's a
fashion statement and I said Mom I can't
go they're going to make fun of me said
Joey if anyone makes fun of you you turn
around and say you don't have a
pair swear to God true on the health of
my children so I'm I I go the punch bowl
and and this guy Frank grabs me says hey
look at Biden nuts and bolts and
everybody started to laugh and I said
Frank you don't have a pair of these I
swear to God I swear to God he turned
and said yeah I have them I have them I
have anyway my theory is that if you
stay connected to these things that
embarrassed you when you were a kid
whatever it was speech impediment or
anxiety or feeling awkward or not being
a good athlete I my list goes on and on
and on um having weird hair having a
weird name I wish I had your hair I'd
trade right now if you want you want
this hair it comes off it's a it's it's
it Velcro on the back yeah if I could do
it I would do it I will mail you this
wig
tomorrow do some polling first on how
people are going to think about that um
but I think what it
does is that it gives you empathy I
think empathy comes from a
sense if you've felt that pain if you
see someone else and you sense that
maybe they're feeling that
pain you're awakens to it and that's I
think the superpower that comes from it
is you have certain you're right when I
got elected uh I was down here hiring
staff I was using Senator Kennedy's
office over in the capital to interview
staff and uh I got a phone call from my
fire department they put a young woman
on the phone uh and she said there's
been an accident you got to come home
December 18th I wasn't sworn in yet and
uh he said there been your wife's
Christmas shop with your kids my kids
were then 13 months old almost three and
almost four and uh she just so nervous
as that they're
dead and I was
enraged by it I remember going out of
the Capal looking up in the dome I swear
to God I'm embarrassed about it about
and I had cut I just
screamed and didn't know where my boys
were alive they were badly injured skull
fracture and bow at every bone of his
body broken first he was in a body cast
arms legs thr
anyway what I learned though is that
after that when I'd show up with a
friend's viewing or family viewing and
they'd stop everything the family would
stop even if we didn't know and they'd
come to me just come to me and I
realized what they're really saying is
he lost what we lost and he and he made
it he's still walking people have to
know that you can persevere you know
yeah and
if you made it through they think well
maybe maybe I can't maybe I will I've
spend uh a lot of time over my career
with families that
are going through tough times yeah
because you know it gives them some
Solace and I look I want to be clear I
was really lucky yeah I had enormous
help by the time I came home my sister
and her husband had given up their
apartment and already moved in to help
me raise the kid kids my brother did we
have an expression in our family for
real if you have to ask it's too late if
you have to ask it's too late never had
to ask and think of the people going
through the stuff that we're talking
about they're Heroes they get up every
day put one foot in front of the other
and do it by themselves so I had an
enormous Advantage dealing with my
things I went through I I try to impart
that to my kids that whatever you're
going through even if you're miserable
right now it's going to yield something
later on of course what you're
describing is the worst thing anybody
can describe and what they're going
through usually is something extremely
minor the scale of it it's the same
principle which is absolutely the scale
varies but help
needed